-You have four brothers?
-I do.
-And you guys are all
pretty close in age?
-Yeah, yeah. So, oldest is 45,
and then I'm 41.
And it goes 41, 40, 38, 36.
-Okay, and, now,
is that close enough
that you guys were all
wailing on each other?
-Oh, yeah. And not one person
was definitively winning.
-Oh, gotcha.
-Yes, so, like, any given day,
it was a coin flip,
because anything was game.
I've been chased with a
chain saw, with kitchen knives,
set on fire.
There was an incident
with a hive of bees.
We tend not to talk about that.
Mustard was involved.
It was weird.
Yeah, so that's life growing up
in West Newbury, Massachusetts.
-You had an actual --
You guys built a wrestling ring
in your basement?
-Yeah, so, to, like, corral us
from actually
not murdering each other.
We ended up locking ourselves
in the basement
and creating our own sports
entertainment federation.
-And so you're young obviously,
but you're doing the thing
that you ended up
doing professionally.
At one point did you think,
"Oh, this might be a career"?
Because I think a lot of people
wrestle in their basement
and don't think,
"This is what I'm going to do."
-I still can't believe
they pay me to do this.
Joke's on you guys!
This is awesome!
[ Applause ]
Aw, thank you, thank you.
The lesson to be learned
out there is love what you do,
because if you love what you do,
it's never a day of work.
So thank you, guys.
Thank you. Thank you.
-I feel lucky
in the exact same way.
You obviously --
This is a -- You know,
it's a half robot-based film,
it's a half car-based film.
You are a car guy.
-Yeah.
-And your actual --
Your first wrestling name
was kind of in the realm --
-Oh, boy. I thought
we sunk the ship at CFO.
-This was -- Somebody
gave you this name, yes?
And you were called
The Prototype?
-I was.
-And was the idea
that you were a half-robot?
-The idea was --
I think the slogan was
"50% man, 50% machine,
100% mayhem!"
-The Prototype!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Don't clap for that.
You definitely
have never seen this
if you were
putting your hands together.
You'd be like,
"Man, you owe me 20 bucks!"
It was awful. It was awful.
-What was your first car?
-So, my first car was
an '84 Coupe DeVille,
which I got at 14 and a half.
-How were you allowed
to get a car at 14 and a half?
-Oh, you know,
I kind of coerced my dad
into putting up half the money.
And I worked
at a very young age.
I got my first job at 13
as a youth league umpire.
-Oh, wow. I did that, as well.
It was really good money.
-Yeah, it was.
It was a fun time.
-It was great.
-Yeah.
-I was a bit eccentric,
but that's another story.
-But didn't you --
My favorite thing about it
was you were doing it at 13,
and it was, like,
the kids were like 10 or 11.
And I loved just that authority.
-Me too. Yes.
I thoroughly abused it, and I
owe a lot of people an apology.
-Did you have -- As an umpire,
did you have like --
Were you happy
with your called strike three?
Did you have a good one?
-I believe you're familiar
with a movie called
"The Naked Gun."
-Yes. You would use those?
-So, when I say I was
a bit eccentric...
For a Little League game
with about 25 parents there.
Full splits. And moonwalks.
-Yeah.
-Poor 11-year-old kid who's
trying to go back to the dugout.
I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry.
-So Coupe DeVille?
-Yeah, but I smoked the
transmission before I was 15,
so I got rid of the car
before I could even drive.
First car I ever bought
with my own money,
I still have to this day.
-Really?
-A 1989 Jeep Wrangler.
It's got 185,000 miles on it.
It's an inline-four.
It is a dog.
But it's beautiful,
and I'll never sell it.
It is not for sale.
-That's fantastic.
Hey, man, congratulations
on everything, as always.
I know you're about to get
back in the ring, as well.
-Yes, December 26th!
The CFO is back!